joe biden getting a new batch of
migrants dropped off at his front door
texas sending a second busload of
illegal immigrants to washington as
governor greg abbott feuds with the
white house over our wide open border
if they're not going to come to the
border i'm going to take the border to
them in washington dc these are all
migrants who have been processed by cbp
and are free to travel so it's nice the
state of texas is helping them get to
their final destination as they await in
their their outcome of their immigration
proceedings and they're all in
immigration proceedings republicans also
calling out biden's hypocrisy on ending
title 42 the covet policy that lets
border agents kick out large groups of
migrants biden is still forcing
americans to mask up on planes for the
next two weeks kill me i wish you would
mask up permanently but that's a story
for another time so mean don't you fine
that was in the prompter it's not your
fault it wasn't the prompter yes um it's
kind of it's kind of i have to admire
abbott for what he's doing he's
basically taking the border crisis on a
road trip you know to visit its baby
daddy